so I'll just start by saying experiments
in art and technology was a group that
was founded in 1966 by the artist Robert
Rauschenberg
by an engineer named Billy kluever who
was a research scientist at Bell Labs at
that time literally the heyday or
basically it was the heyday of Bell Labs
which was the ground zero for sort of
everything as we know it none of what
we're doing right now would be possible
without the invention of the transistor
for example all of these breakthrough
inventions happen at Bell Labs and it
was really the center of the
telecommunications revolution so this
engineer at Bell gets together with
these artists some of whom are really
you know prominent at the time and they
are they've there have been they've sort
of met each other through some just
really almost chance social circles but
also through some art world friends in
common and you know Jasper Johns needed
a neon wanted a neon light in the shape
of a letter the letter R for one of his
paintings and he didn't want a cord
running from the painting to an
electrical socket so somehow he got
hooked up with kluever this engineer
from Bell and said can he do this well
it turns out it was kind of a
complicated problem at the time how do
you make a battery-powered neon light
that's small enough to fit behind a
painting etc etc etc well he did it so
they had these various collaborations
but then Rauschenberg and kluever the
artists and the engineers thought why
can't this week why can't we bring this
to everyone why can't every artist who's
curious about you know making something
float have access to an engineer who
works on pneumatic technology so how
could you create these collaborations
and then how could you even scale them
or grow them so that this becomes a mass
sort of phenomenon so they said about
trying to basically start to
get the word out to get artisan
engineers together the first real
project they did that they undertook was
probably you know one of the largest
endeavors at the time it involved over
40 engineers and artists and it was this
performance series that took place in
New York in at the Armory which was a
huge cavernous space and basically to
get to make the performance what became
the performance pieces they paired
artists choreographers musicians
composers with engineers most of them
from Bell just because what was that
process of pairing them like well it was
very tumultuous so they had meetings and
again it was very ad hoc in other words
it was it was really a word-of-mouth
thing so kluever would bring in friends
from Bell rauschenberg and Robert
Wittman and other artists would bring in
friends from their circle this happened
to include John Cage David Tudor Yvonne
Rainer really people that would become
extremely well-known afterward but
already prominent at the time so they
had freewheeling meetings actually held
them at a high school in Berkeley
Heights New Jersey which was near Perth
house they would go up there were people
who live sort of more upstate so they
would go there and they were just really
trying to literally brainstorm to bounce
ideas off one another and you know of
course the artists wanted things like
you know I want a missile that floats I
want you know a light bulb that will
explode I want walkie talkies I want
remote control
I want sound that will respond to the
viewer as they're walking through space
in real time and like any tech person
knows non tech people think technology
can do everything all at once already so
they were really just pie in the sky and
I think the engineers were really
shocked but I also really enthusiastic
because they hadn't had experiences like
that in large measure before so this
really created a lot of excitement it
created a lot of tensions there were a
lot of fights a lot of conflict as well
just a lot of pressure because in the
end they I think they signed up for
creating you know a very let's say
ambitious set of performances on a large
scale in New York and at the end of the
day you know very little was tested or
tried out and there were long delays
nearly 10,000 visitors over the course
of these essentially 20 nights yeah so
like just so I understand the timeframe
yeah they they decide like there's just
one project with the neon behind the
painting with a battery ok this is cool
we should have more of this
they then like book the armory like nine
months ago my fast forwarding but
basically they were they had proposed
they got together let's say maybe 10 of
them ok but really spearheaded by
rauschenberg and kluever and then it
kind of built a bit and again this is
just this really almost contingent
aspect to it
Coover Swedish there is a Swedish
performance festival in Stockholm and
they thought well let's apply to do
something for that that fell through
they they EA T claimed later that it was
because the performance festival didn't
want to give they didn't like the idea
that the artists would give so much
agency to the engineers and that they
would kind of be this freewheeling thing
regardless that fell through so then
they just thought okay how can we
produce these performances that we'd
already started brainstorming about and
everyone's really excited about and you
know again Rauschenberg
and some of these other artists were
quite prominent at the time so you know
the armory was suggested as a venue
because they wanted they wanted to test
out literally physical scale and in the
armory
there are echo times of up to
five seconds so people interested in
sound in remote control in video or
basically in projection were interested
in this very large physical scale
already so they they booked it but again
I guess part of it is that some of these
artists were already quite prominent and
so on opening night for this performance
series you have senator Jacob Javits and
his wife Eva
his wife is a prominent arts patron you
have the sort of who's who of the New
York art world but also of the
avant-garde demi-monde and they're all
there on mass and they're all really mad
because they're waiting it's like
breaking right things aren't working and
so eventually when things did start to
work you know really extraordinary and
interesting things happen for example in
Rauschenberg's performance piece to make
a long story short one of the
technologies they got and used was
infrared and at the time infrared was a
classified a military technology they
ended up getting infrared cameras from a
Japanese supplier and so that one part
of the performance was turning all the
lights off and in the dark then training
these infrared cameras on hundreds of
performers that assembled on the floor
of the armory and so you got these very
ghostly spectral images of these people
for the audience at large and again you
know that was an extraordinary thing
that happened it's like as if today you
would have an artist that had access to
the Pentagon and was spending time you
know toying around there so that was
really unprecedented and from there they
got momentum even more they grew to a
few hundred people and then anyone could
really become a member you just signed
you fill out a form and you sent it in
and so at their peak by around 1970 they
had nearly 5,000 members what did it
mean to be a member so basically to be a
member you could get access to this now
in other words you could fill out what
you're interested in whether you're on
whatever field you're in if you're an
artist you could say I'm interested in
new plastics and Holograms and also
cybernetics and then if you are an
engineer you could say well this is my
disciplinary expertise I'm also really
fascinated by you know kinetic sculpture
or I really like you know dropping acid
like how are people discovering this is
like pre-internet they're just like okay
I'm into acid I guess I know how that
makes it to your town but part of the
whole thing was outreach and they're
very they made a concerted effort
obviously not only to reach out to
artists but then to go to I Triple E
which was the you know Engineering
Society they had a hanukkah had a booth
with Manning a booth there I'm handing
out flyers so again it's like let's take
this to the trade fair to conferences
they gave talks they did you know almost
like not really publicity but it's a
tours of schools the university was of
course a whole other connector and what
you see as well is this this network of
what becomes or was a kind of academic
military industrial complex all of these
people are really in communication and
so EA T is basically saying well how can
we get the word out so can you explain
the actual Russian Berg like piece at
the Armory because I thought that was
particularly cool yeah so Rauschenberg
had decided to he was very interested
again in first of all remote control
this what he kind of thought of as
action at a distance
you know how can you make something else
happen but not be physically tethered to
it he's also interested in sound effects
in sonic sort of annoys as well as you
know experiments basically in acoustics
and the other part of it is really
almost creating something let's say
poetic out of people's movements and he
was also interested in games and at the
time a number of artists had already or
were already exploring the sort of
structure of the game and it was also
very much a conscious reference to game
theory even and so all of these layers
are definitely you know they're
Rauschenberg's piece basically set up in
this huge cavernous expanse of the
armory a tennis match but it wasn't a
regular tennis match he set up a tennis
court
he had the artist frank stella who at
the time was actually taking tennis
lessons from a tennis instructor named
Mimi Khan auric so the tennis instructor
and frank stella are on the tennis court
and they play a game of tennis but it so
happens that the racquets the tennis
racquets are actually hot-wired so each
time you hit the ball a resounding
amplified a microphone would pick up an
amplified sound that would resonate
throughout the armory and it triggered a
huge bank of lights to be turned off so
with every volley a successive set of
lights would be turned off so by the end
of the game which has no winner or loser
the armory is in complete darkness and
then that's when these infrared cameras
were turned on and a mass of sort of
they're not really performers there were
people that Rauschenberg sent out sort
of vague instructions to but they were
just supposed to gather on the floor and
do maybe make a motion like pull your
ear or touch the person next to you just
these sort of very vague instructions so
that's what they were doing assembled on
the floor and the image of them via
infrared is then projected above on
these huge screens and then at the end
of that they turned one spotlight on
the choreographer Seimone 40 came out
and was being carried and was singing a
sort of Italian folk song so again this
is all you know it's not a regular
narrative it doesn't really make any
sense but it what it did was really push
it investigated some questions around
performance play sound imaging
technology and also the idea that you
could have you could have a performance
didn't have to be about a climactic
spectacle it was about some other kind
of experience and a kind of experience
that the artist hoped you wouldn't have
had before and that you know really that
was the case of course the first night
the rackets didn't work so they were or
the lights this the trigger for the
lights didn't work so they were actually
manually turned off the light you know
sort of jerry-rigging or you know retro
actively you know making the piece
happen later it did but to you know
again it was it was really a test and an
experiment in every sense of the word
and at the time you know people didn't
really they didn't really sort of
understand that that's what it was so
I've been wondering this the whole time
right because it like so much of this
technology was so new at that lake to
the extent that you had never even seen
an infrared camera right how are people
talking about this art and Technology
overlap because I know where I think I
imagine how people talk about it now but
how are people talking about it at the
time well you have a couple different
attitudes one is you know wonder and
astonishment this is amazing isn't this
so incredible and exciting and part of
that is a very futurist strain of
language which is you know people
basically trying to predict what's going
to happen and having fun doing so just
like the artists were in a way as well
but you have a lot of people
theorizing about the future of
communication the future of images the
future of human perception and so
there's a lot of literature around that
from you know every sort of end of the
spectrum and then there are people who
are extremely critical and wary and at
the time you know this is the height of
the anti-vietnam protests this is a
moment when you know well 10 years or so
after the military industrial complex is
coined as a term it is a concept that
begins to really take root and
particularly among the avant-garde among
the counterculture among the very
artists that and some of the engineers
that are part of EA T so they actually
came under a lot of flack I mean there
are articles actually written in art
form as as well as elsewhere that
essentially accused EA T of being
complicit with you know the military and
taking that as far as you might even
yeah go so that was also part of why I
think EA T had a very conflicted
reception at the time and why maybe
people haven't heard so much about it
since then as well and you get it really
crystallizes both utopian and the
dystopian attitudes toward technology at
the time and what arts role was to
either explore that or in fact critique
and negate that mmm ok and so this led
to the automation house but like I have
so what was it exactly do you see that
part of the video no it isn't crazy ok
so what is it actually called au
automated house it's called this is like
they're the collaboration between I
think I got this right American
Foundation on automation and employment
so basically this argument that they
were having at the time which is exactly
like the same thing as today yes like
the robots are gonna take your job and
so it's kluever and he and the people
and I forget the guy's name who is the
organizer of that Oh Theodore keel you
Turkey yeah create this building
together right
yes yeah which is the like future of
life house like what I don't really
understand what it's supposed to be well
basically what this is it around in 1968
1969 dat had been moving around they had
a loft ooh they had various places to
sort of meet and they they viewed the
physical space is actually an important
part of what they were doing because as
much as they were actually building what
would become a real network that was
sprawled globally they also wanted what
they called a place to try things out
you know a testing ground and so they
thought various physical spaces like a
loft could be that place then they got
into again through Rauschenberg in large
part talks with this group the American
Foundation on automation and employment
and Theodore keel was the guy who had
started this was the head of this
organization and he was a labor lawyer
he'd actually become well known for
mediating a massive I think was a
newspaper workers strike in the early
60s so suddenly all of these concerns
about collective action about technology
and and labor come to the fore and
everyone is really worried that
automation if the robots will take our
jobs John F Kennedy had said you know
Automation is the greatest threat facing
humanity today and so there was alarm at
the time it was they didn't even know
about artificial intelligence so you
know it was it was really a widespread
fear and so this group that the labor
lawyer was sort of running was actually
trying to literally mediate these
concerns and they thought that they
could find solutions to not only accept
but embrace technology and recognize
that it was a reality that it wasn't
going away but also then somehow change
the
fear of labor so that labor that people
could still be employed
it's just that what they did would
change and again this is obviously so
it's a very positive utopian view of oh
yes it's almost very practical you know
they really wanted to try and solve this
problem but then it dovetailed very
nicely with what EA T was trying to do
which was to say you know how can we
pragmatically understand the force of
technology in a way that you know I
think people were really almost
willfully blind - in other words you
reject it and you don't even want to
understand it you you can't really
understand it and therefore you're just
you know gonna condemn it so they really
wanted to bring people from different
knowledge domains fields of expertise
together and try and solve some of these
problems so they decided to build or
renovate a town house in New York to
create a Center for job training for
workshops about automation and
technology for art exhibitions for EA t
to have their kind of headquarters there
as well for classes and they got two
young architects it's you essentially
retrofit the building with
closed-circuit television cameras video
monitors they had a video workstation
there where one of the projects they did
was actually convert a bunch of really
experimental film pieces to video and
then do the first cable broadcast of
artists television programming pretty
much of all time and this was in 1970-71
okay where was it broadcast it was
broadcast on local access cable access
in New York that's pretty cool channels
and they published the schedule in the
village but it's like having a few other
newspapers or TV Guide you'll see it
like Andy Warhol's you know dot dot it's
being screened at 8:00 p.m. on Tuesday
you know so that was really quite
amazing and today we're trying to create
some kind of studio / laboratory where
all these things could have
then but it started to it again really
highlighted how despite all of the
tensions and conflicts surrounding their
relationships to technology EA t really
did have a social mission and was
extremely political and wanted to you
know it change both social and political
aspects of life but it just let's say
from a different vantage point than
maybe other other artists did at the
time yeah because it seems very
practical right like it was yeah it was
yeah because what ended up happening
with the house which is the my concern
it was basically became eventually
became a gallery so you know again it's
it was both practical and really
impractical because you know many of
their ideas again or many of their plans
sort of petered out and and the I would
say one of the most amazing and
fantastic but then also cataclysmic
events for them was when EA T was
commissioned to construct and realize
the Pepsi pavilion at the World's Fair
in Osaka in 1970 and I think I talked
about this you did yeah
but basically that was the biggest
single collaborative project they took
on and it was truly global I mean they
worked with Japanese artists engineers
European artists engineers obviously
American artists engineers they tested
it in LA but they created a 180 degree
hemispherical mirror dome that was
inflated made out of inflated mylar
essentially which was the same
technology that was being used for the
first telecommunication satellites it's
like they would launch a reflective
balloon into space and you're literally
bouncing waves cool but instead they
used that technology or essentially
through much trial and error Jerry
rigged it so that they could create an
inflated mirror dome and then when you
walked inside you there were all of
these sound effects
different textures different projections
and performances but the mirror dome
itself created essentially
three-dimensional near holographic
inverted reflections and you could
capture this in photographs oh if
they're incredible photographs of this
as well but basically they took on this
massive project and it you know by all
rights was actually really created
unprecedented experiences that were
literally giving you both real and
virtual images as they called them but
Pepsi to make a long story short when
the pavilion open to the public
they basically thought this is too weird
so huge they're also huge budget cost
overruns there was also a fog
surrounding the whole of fog sculpture
surrounding the entire pavilion I can't
even get into all of these things people
thought the fog was a fire so they said
look the first day they sent you know
fire trucks screaming anyway
Pepsi kind of thought well actually this
is really weird
and and so there was a breakdown
actually there was a essentially a legal
dispute and at the end of the day eh he
sort of got kicked out of the pavilion
they were literally smuggling their
tapes like they're sort of you know
8-track tapes for programs out of the
pavilion and the end result is that
Pepsi replaced all of these experimental
sort of John Cage slash David Tudor
composed soundtracks with it's a small
world and and that was effectively
enough to like burn everyone out it was
traumatic I think for everyone and I
think the whole thing was traumatic I
mean if they still went on for you know
a number of years by after let's say
that really I think was was tough and
yet you know again I would say it was
the it really demonstrated how global
they could
actually and how they could construct a
global team that would create something
of a very ambitious scale and it just it
also just became an object lesson and
all of the difficulties of course
surrounding well cuz what I've been
wondering was that the the first thing
that got me into this was I was reading
the conversations with Robert Irwin but
it was amazing I love that book and it's
like just like one sentence it talks
about him hanging out with Richard
Fineman do you know much about this like
I I want to watch that movie I want that
and it's like so such little information
online I don't know if there's footage
of it by Robert Irwin and Richard Serra
sir I always mispronounce the name in
like an anechoic chamber they're like
but that's a famous sort of interaction
where Robert Irwin Irwin was
experimenting with basically would shape
his work where he's really interested in
shutting out all sensation and then he
goes on to create works that that
explore the guns felt or this perceptual
limit in the same way that an anechoic
chamber does but yeah Richard Fineman
was a member of eate so as Robert Irwin
so we're a lot of physicists you know
again was part of this kind of crazy
network of people and what was great was
that there were a lot of not a lot but
there were definitely a number of
analogous collaboration programs that
were like EA T often modeled after that
it one was this program where a win was
sort of meeting a lot of these people
through it was for an exhibition at
LACMA the LA County Museum of Art and it
was called or in technology is all very
confusing yeah but it was basically a
for an exhibition so they were very much
inspired by EA T but this exhibition was
sort of like the endpoint so in other
words you would Commission all these
collaborations that they paired but it
was this very corporate thing right like
they're all these companies like yes eh
he was also embroiled with all of these
companies as well like Lockheed Martin
you know basically the aerospace and
stretchy in Southern California like the
Jet Propulsion Laboratory
that's where urban went so they they did
the same thing they paired artists with
engineers but it was ultimately to end
up back in the museum that's why I find
really fascinating and then to me the
difference is that eate it was it took
the opposite trajectory it tried to
explode in scale and it could not be
confined by the museum it did not fit
into any of the traditional institutions
did everything they build was it was at
all site-specific
not necessarily I mean you know what
part of what they wanted to do and what
they did create was almost even a set of
equipment so for example you could go
check out the weird hybrid control panel
that had been invented essentially or
engineered for this other performance
now it just exists there you can go take
it and it's like a library you can check
it out and use it for something else and
and and yet the other thing is that
often what they created does not conform
to traditional genres of sculpture or
painting or drawings and so a lot of
what they made was either lost or some
of it's sitting in disrepair and like an
engineer's garage somewhere an artist's
studio and so the paper trail so to
speak well they left a voluminous paper
trail but not a not a trail of let's say
traditional art objects huh and that's I
think also part of why it's been hard
for people to wrap their heads around
what this was or what they did but this
is like an ongoing issue in the art
world right like maintaining all this
stuff yeah I mean even I don't know the
history of it nearly like you do but the
like all the tangley stuff the things
that break themselves are amazing yeah
but they like the museum kind of takes
it fun out of it because they'll be like
a red button that you can hit like once
an hour and then all like this thing
will just dance and so they yes yeah and
they're many it's funny there are a lot
of exhibitions even nowadays where those
things still don't aren't working or
like the technicians the conservators
have to come and you know sort of
they're always panicked but tingly
actually was really one of the first
works that kluever the e8e
engineer they collaborated on a piece
that was basically a kinetic sculpture
that destroyed itself in the Museum of
Modern Art sculpture garden in 1960 and
of course it didn't really it sort of
just short-circuited so it was again
supposed to be I think kind of
spectacular and in the end it just kind
of fizzled out but that was one of
Hoover's first collaborations with an
artist but yes so the idea of
incorporating new technologies and new
materials or even unorthodox materials
and unorthodox technologies you know
that is a really interesting problem for
the production of art especially
starting around the 1950s 60s 70s and
even more so now of course with you know
God knows what you know an artist is
using Bitcoin I have no idea what
they're going to do in the future you
wouldn't believe the actions you got on
Twitter by the way like people are
sending in stuff it's very practically
Wikipedia that again but just to sort of
finish that thought I think what was
really amazing specifically about some
of what EA T made and this is present in
for example a number a lot of
Rauschenberg's
own collaborative artworks from the time
that he made with kluever under the
auspices of EA t is that rauschenberg
said look I'm making this thing with a
transistor radio right now and you know
they've done all these complex things to
it to make you know sort of the effects
they want at the time in the sixties
transistor radio was not a mass
technology it had just come on to the
market was very new thing fast forward
to the 90s this it's this piece which is
a sort of sculptor that has these radios
embedded in it is acquired by the
central Pompidou in Paris well it's not
her Pompidou is a very funny building
again to make a long story short it's a
very weird piece of architecture but it
acts like a Faraday cage so it was
blocking all signal also at the time
that they had constructed the piece in
the 60s in the mid sixties a.m. was like
FM and FM was like a.m. in terms of
programming so a.m. had more pop music
etc F
had more sort of news blah blah blah
Rauschenberg wanted us i think at the
time it was FM and then so they wanted
to switch it to a.m. as well
anyway let's just say that in the 90s
they had to do this whole retrofitting
and then successively update the radios
and receivers in this piece over time to
the point where now their digital radios
and receivers in the sculpture in this
in this metal sculpture from 1965 and
rauschenberg said that's great
do whatever you want to do and in a way
he's taking this idea of the ready-made
which is this revolutionary 20th century
idea and he's saying the ready-made
itself can be updated it can sort of
change and adapt to technological
obsolescence and that is really you know
fascinating and groundbreaking well it's
particularly interesting when you like
take the modern eye and bring it into
these exhibits where like things that
that are supposed to represent the
future now look like this kit retro like
there's the I forget what it's called
but it does it at the Tate that big
tower of TVs yeah yeah and you look like
cool I go in very 1984 esque but I don't
think it's intended or was intended that
way it wasn't but some so many artists
again it's a sliding scale many artists
at the time are actually interested in
obsolete technologies and in exploring
those at the same time there are other
artists who are interested in the you
know the newest latest thing and that's
what they want a question I often ask
artists that are alive still is you know
if you could do it all over again would
you use a different technology to
achieve the effect that you wanted back
then and some say yes I've even heard an
artist say yes I actually want to take
back my works that are in the museum and
change them and put them back which
museums really don't want it's a it
points up this crazy contradiction or
this conundrum that people are facing
some artists say no I wouldn't change a
thing I want it to reflect that medium
that that sort of form of the
and that was that's something I want to
preserve so it just depends on what you
know you were trying to do and and what
questions you are trying to ask okay do
you have thoughts and so Kat and I both
went to Venice this year I we know yet
I'll be clear like it was the first one
of those I've never been to anything you
know okay it only happens every two
years so until you went right because
you wrote a review yeah we had a whole
yeah series of pieces and there's a
distinct lack of technology at this one
right that's an interesting question
I wouldn't you know that again I think
points to what maybe has changed between
let's say the mid 60's and now which is
that of course consumer technology has
expanded to the extent that everyone has
a computer in their pocket so it's so
ubiquitous that in a way I wouldn't say
that the the bein all I for example was
devoid of technology I think it was
everywhere in a lot of different ways
but this exhibition in particular was
focusing on let's say an investigation
of ideas about primitivism about
indigenous cultures about nature about
spirituality and those are definitely
things that you know in a way that
explains why you saw a lot of let's say
more traditional craft or form yeah in
the show so you're totally right it's
just that I would say a we often don't
notice it as much because it's not for
grounded as the raise on debt of an
artwork it's just there right and on the
flip side yes it might I would say that
people are interested right now in
exploring the flip side of the
acceleration of technology and its
omnipresence they're interested in also
slowing things down in other kinds of
perception or in even countering some of
the kinds of media saturation I did I
did love sharpening a MacBook
there was it the snow monkeys remember
snow I just was thinking about actually
was one of my favorite pieces or two
pieces in the show and yeah exactly so
again such a simple idea with the snow
monkeys but of course that's video but
then with the sharpening the MacBook Air
again a very simple idea but very
extremely sharp so infinite n yeah and
thinking about like the legacy of vit
who do you think is doing some of the
most interesting work within that you
know kind of intersection of art and
technology you know again I would say
what's what's exciting in a sense is
that so many artists have so much more
access to advanced technology simply
because of the prolific the
proliferation of these advanced
technologies in everyday life on the
flip side you know I would say the the
the cloisters in which technology is
actually being sort of produced or
created now are still in many ways as
walled off to you know the guy on the
street as they were before so some of
the artists that I think are really
either a pushing the boundaries of what
art and technology can do together but
also of really looking at technologies
or making it a point to try and engage
technologies that most ordinary people
are artists wouldn't really have access
to one of them is Trevor Paglen who for
example he well he's kind of a crazy guy
he has a series of incredible
photographs that are basically taken
from remote sites and with very special
camera technology of drone planes so
they're these beautiful photographs
often of a incredibly brilliant night
sky and then there's a tiny speck and
it's a drone so he has to do all of
these things to get that sort of picture
and and what he's doing in many
different ways
in lots of other projects as well is to
try and render visible or sensible to us
things that are absolutely not visible
to us normally or even physically so for
example he is really interested in all
of these automated technologies that are
post vision so to speak literally things
that we cannot visualize because they
don't take place in an optical realm so
how do you start to even talk about it
or engage it or make someone somehow
perceived get some sense of what those
processes are and he's really someone
who I think has done that yeah I mean I
was just about to jump into some of
these questions from Twitter but I mean
this is a it's a new experience for us
too
um I should retype some of these
questions because it makes me sound like
I can't read although I have like a
fourth grade reading level project okay
so there this annasophia Almagro I also
butcher everyone's name she asked the
question about blockchain are you uh at
it yeah I don't mean to be patronizing
like what's your level in the know we
actually published a piece about um
Bitcoin and the blockchain it was a
media study it was by a Media Studies
person and I will say I relied on a lot
of help because my as I literally just
by coincidence My partner is
technologists and actually the rest of
my family are all scientists as well
which is explain something I guess but
by I we had to do a lot of research to
make sure we were accurately
characterizing the technology and yeah I
learned a lot obviously when we worked
on that piece okay so you're on board
then I have a crazy yeah although you
know this is like a year now two years
ago so but you can test my recall it's a
well cabinet can jump in at any point so
is blockchain being used to track
authenticity
in art so meaning digital art Wow not to
my knowledge yet not to my knowledge yes
I don't think I've heard I've heard of
one one project yeah we cuz you get the
idea right so it's tracking authenticity
and that is my interpretation is that
it's incredibly difficult to create
valuable digital art if it's a like you
know falling apart because like you know
your browser is no longer compatible but
also you know if you like Photoshop
paint something you can just duplicate
it infinitely right so you have the
signature on this the original okay so
maybe maybe not I mean it to me I not to
my knowledge yet but I haven't really
looked into it in this way and I guess
again what I would say is that it's an
incredibly well it's a very intuitive
but it's also a perverse idea because I
think a lot of artists right now who are
exploring something like the blockchain
are interested in disrupting well that's
a terrible word to you so scratched in
in going against sort of Orthodox
valuation in the first place so but yeah
I mean so they might not care as much
about authenticity or of like a regional
piece or yeah they actively want to
subvert authenticity
yeah and that's been something that
again actually you could say almost the
entire history of Modern Art is about
challenging authenticity and authorship
and so we've been through in our sort of
realm many different iterations of
people trying to test this in different
ways and so in technology is one of them
right it's like saying that it's
removing to use a technological system
is often to remove you as a human single
individual and your whatever imprimatur
that may be on something it's to replace
that with a system that's determined in
advance or might use a chance operation
so these are all legacies in arc that
again are really informing I think
people's attitudes towards even the
newest technology okay so I'm sure
people are you know everyone's always
interested in valuation outside of
the artists themselves well it's tricky
all right but it's all made up yeah I
mean I don't know oh okay I don't know
if are you about Damien Hirst found
objects hot or not are you allowed to
comment on this alright next question
is it still art if a machine creates it
yes and for the reasons that I just
enumerated I think that this becomes a
philosophical question but at the end of
the day in most cases up to now at our
point in history someone a human still
has to trigger that process let's say go
even if then everything else is
determined by an algorithm or by you
know program and and yet artists were
interested in challenging they were
interested in using machines precisely
to challenge this traditional notion of
authorship which they associated with an
outmoded model of being basically and to
challenge systems really of not only of
capitalism but also of basically Western
philosophy that is often privileges the
author and it's the author as a white
male so these are all things that get
challenged at different periods in
history and they people are using
machines to do that
the weird thing now is in it again I
would point to the work of someone like
Trevor Paglen or another artist
Haroun Farooqi where as Pavlin himself
is kind of characterized these artists
are confronting the both amazing and
terrifying prospect of totally automated
completely automated systems that don't
need the human just to set off that go
button and that are you know acting or
using deep learning or using all of
these different processes that do not
entail humans and again yeah
I think you know artists and art viewers
will still be interested in someone who
somehow finds a way to investigate that
art well so this is the so we had dug oh
yeah oh you do this the name I don't
know him personally I just I know about
him but actually again this is nothing
in the video but like my partner because
he's in music technology he again was
like oh I was like oh so I was weeding
up about him as well but yeah so he was
on the podcast before which is great
okay yeah so he's awesome and his whole
thing is right like this is just a tool
and he often he cited a Brian Eno quote
which is basically saying like the the
style is defined by the glitch of it you
know if the electric guitar with Jimi
Hendrix was the distortion you know like
vinyl or tapes or whatever and he had
been talking about how when photography
came out people are criticizing I was
like this isn't art like this is just a
reproduction yeah do you think the same
thing is just gonna be happening with us
like machine learning comes into art
creation or 3d printing or basically my
question is is this a constant in the
art world
yes I'll probably never live to see the
day when someone doesn't say my kid
could do that so that is a question and
but but again it's you know to me the
real question is what is what does it
mean to introduce a glitch into
something what does it mean to explore
the perfection of a mechanical or a
computational system what does it mean
to try and basically challenge the
legacy of virtuosic skill in other words
the reason photography created a crisis
for art was that it said you know if the
if one of the stated aims of painting
was to somehow reproduce the world in
the most wonderful way possible now you
have a machine that just does it
automatically and so what how do you how
can you
possibly try to understand a different
way of creating that is not mimetic that
is not about reproduction and how can
you try and understand a mode of
construction that might even challenge
or critique those systems of
reproduction and that's when you get
into the 20th century and you know Steve
rush you know saying I have the simplest
pattern but then in realization or in
its realization you get an incredibly
singular you know amazing sonic
experience but you know people are
playing precisely with pulling the
subject out completely the author out
completely but then also you know the
the realization that you can never quite
fully do that so there's always these
you know this tension between sort of
total chance total system and total
control gotcha
okay so we just have a couple questions
left this is a yeah this has been great
I mean it's a big topic but it's I would
say also the funny thing is regardless
of a tool a lot of bad art has been made
you know look it's it that's what I mean
about it's not just of course about the
tool it's about what you do with the
tool but also maybe you're creating a
new tool in the first place and and
that's what I think artists have really
pushed the limits of what you know what
sensation is what perception is right
material is what we've adapt yeah yeah
and so when your or even predict I mean
they might be the forecasters in a way
of what comes to pass as well seems like
it in some cases yeah in some cases
they're great chagrin what are that what
oh yeah what happened in like automation
house that didn't come to life or that
did come to life like that they called
that well so one project was they had a
series of projects they called projects
outside art which again gives you some
idea of what they're trying to do and
one of the things that
really very funny is a project that was
called children and communication so the
artist Robert Whitman kind of
spearheaded this project and and again
part of this is about with these new
tools of communication how can we
explore democratizing communication and
networks of communication so they had
this idea to set up multiple stations
around the city where different school
children of different socio-economic
brackets like in different places could
go and have access to teletype machines
basically primitive facts and telex
machines and so they could then there
are sessions just like go and why don't
you communicate with these other this
led to a al chat and mass comm generally
you know but anyway so the children
wrote to each other and of course there
are all these like funny jokes that then
weirdly it kind of went off the rails
and kids were using profanity to each
other like it was a very interesting
funny sort of experiment and even I
would say as a testament to how
architectural and formal experience was
still really important to these artists
and engineers the the sites in which the
children were playing with these
machines were specifically devised as
these kind of low light tents that for
whatever reason they thought this would
be an interesting environment into
intimate environment I don't know but it
was really you know something where then
they explored telex communication with
they set up telex stations for adults on
the occasion of another project in a
meadow vaad india in stockholm in tokyo
in new york in LA and they were having
people ask questions about what they
thought the future would be like so
again it's this very you know in a way
idealistic vision of how
people might exchange information across
a global network but also with questions
that were very much geared toward you
know fear of what the future might bring
yeah
what um will you make a future
prediction about like how these art and
technology communities can work together
because I agree with you that both of
them seem kind of in the same way like
accessible and completely inaccessible
if you're not like part of the club or
whatever what's your future prediction
on their relationship well they're both
highly specialized and and that's part
of why I think you see this isolation
and and that's precisely those were
precisely the terms that EA T was using
back in the 60s as well how can we bring
these fields together that are
developing an isolation in a dangerous
potentially dangerous way but again I
think part of it is on the one hand art
actually has a track record of creating
public institutions or that there are
public institutions that have been
created for viewing and experiencing art
theoretically one wishes they were more
even more public or more accessible but
they're there and I think the same thing
I would hope might be created or really
be augmented for technology which is to
say really creating a public institution
or a public sphere for technological
knowledge and experience in the same way
that a museum is in an ideal scenario a
civic institution that's really for an
audience of anyone who wants to go in
reality of course we know that's not
always the case but you know that's the
aim and I guess I would say that the
effort to make a public institution has
to exist because everyone thought the
internet was going to be that you know
democratizing final utopia and instead
we've seen the flip side of that which
is the development of ever specialized
ever atomized ever more esoteric and
inward-looking conversations or even
if you'd call it a conversation but just
nodes so how do we start to really
invert that and and instill a sense of
what a public sphere could be for both
art and technology and only then I think
with those I think domains really be
able to talk to each other
mm-hmm you had to take down your pay
wall I agree if someone would pay me I
would take down the pic you pay us all
to make this great content I would
definitely take a great with you know
it's you know that's the conundrum of
yeah of creating content today and I
would say that it is you know again the
conundrum of copyright copyleft all of
these things which is I firmly believe
that information wants to be free to
quote another you know utopian guys buy
it right now it's the information there
wouldn't be any information in many ways
if if the people weren't there who could
have a livelihood and that's the tough
sort of paradox of our situation now
then ya know yes I get it my only my
last question you have any more
questions I might I'll see what you okay
yeah well I always liked it you know
recommended reading I gave that to you
as like a pre question so I didn't want
to waste it well one book that is I
think you know a very great and general
sort of argument about some of the
historical shifts we've been talking
about from the 1960s
60s to the present is a book by Fred
Turner called from counterculture to
cyber culture and he really traces the
transformation of the ideals of the
counterculture
which were to you know fight the system
bring it down into the system of Silicon
Valley and how those aspirations and and
even Styles really got incorporated into
you know the most successful sort of
wing of capitalism today I think that's
a really strong book for anyone who
wants to understand some of these
dynamics another book I'll say is more
esoteric but again I think it's good to
just plug this because that's part of my
own perverse desire to do this but the
book by this art historian named Maria
Gough and it's called the artist as
producer and that's actually about
Russian revolutionary art and it's about
a moment in time when in one of the
instances that it covers is what's
called productivism and it's when
artists as part of wanting to create a
new society which you know again failed
for all different kinds of reasons but
they wanted to and they successfully
actually went into infiltrated the
factory the laboratory they basically
became organizers so they were artists
were devising new ways of organizing
labor and sort of subverting the whole
conventional wisdom about fordist you
know assembly line production and so
they it became a social experiment and a
technological one and an organizational
one and the artists were literally
driving that so again it's a it's a
weird crazy moment in history but I
think it's also really today it's
absolutely applicable and I think it's
you know part of what this is is a
history of things that that people
thought of but never came to pass and I
think you know in our culture we're
often taught if it wasn't successful
then you shouldn't pay attention to it
but actually I think the opposite is
true because then you'll never know what
still might be possible in the future
and so you have to explore all of these
basically paths not taken and this was
one of them which I happen to find you
know really really fascinating I would
also put in a plug for reading trying to
read you know pay for going to see art
which still exists
IRL and well that's why you're here we
should plug in what
seriously plug the show and oh sorry yes
well there are a number of really
interesting shows on right now there's a
show at CCA wadis here in San Francisco
that's exploring art and Technology even
well there's a lot of shows you know
that are going up in the near future one
show at the Museum of Modern on New York
was the rauschenberg exhibition and that
covered some of this material I would
also put in a plea or not a plea but
just I think it would be exciting for
people to try and read art criticism as
well writing about art now and as I said
I think the best art criticism can
really speak to multiple audiences and
that people from really different
backgrounds or people who aren't
specialists can take something away from
good writing about art someone else
might take something else away from it
but at its best it can offer that and
where would you start well with Art
Forum I strive to you know we strive to
create the best art criticism is there
like okay so do you know who gate Alize
is guy who knows all these profiles yeah
is there like you know someone who could
go into the past like just pick a writer
I was like oh man this is like iconic
start here oh yeah definitely I would
say Clement Greenberg he is he was wrong
on a lot about a lot of things but a
he's an amazing writer and be he reading
that criticism will tell you a lot about
the entire edifice of what art is today
all the battles that were being fought
the kinds of art that were being made
that basically are still the kind of
let's say foundation against which
artists are responding in some degree or
trying to you know obviously push beyond
still the other thing is he was often
writing for journals
even newspapers and it's it's very clear
and and very it's very much a polemic
it's very much an argument and that was
from a time when the stakes seemed
really high in a way that almost seems
ridiculous or impossible today at the
time critics in the 50s and then in the
60s were battling it out and as one
critic put it they were literally
fighting for the soul of Western
civilization so you you uh you then you
get a sense of what people held what
they were holding art accountable for
and and culture accountable for and I
think that's really important
you